Shhh you hear that?
Yeah I don’t either… but it’s making
me feel creeped out.
Hey guys julia here for DNews
The world is loud and noisy.
And it seems to be only getting noisier.
Obviously exposure to loud noises can cause
hearing damaging.
But some studies like one published in the
British Medical Bulletin, show that it cause
a range of ill health effects, like anxiety
and stress, and another study showed it may
even raise blood pressure . And that’s just
the sounds you can hear.
There’s a whole world of sound that’s
below our range of hearing that can also be
damaging.
Infrasound typically describes sound below
20 hertz.
Usually, it’s too low for humans to pick
up, yet some animals communicate in this range.
Like elephants vocalize in a low rumble that
we can’t hear.
But infrasound can be artificial too: loudspeakers
and public address systems, industrial machinery,
that kind of thing, can kick out sounds that
are too low in frequency for humans to hear,
but can make us sick.
A study published in the journal indoor and
built environment found that infrasound could
be contributing to a condition called “sick-building
syndrome”.
A condition where office workers complain
of nausea, dizziness, migraine, fatigue and
tinnitus with no attributable cause.
Yet this study suggests that infrasound, typically
of about 7hz, might be responsible.
Unfortunately, infrasound isn’t regulated
all that well.
A recent report in the Proceedings of the
Royal Society A questions the idea of what
makes up “safe” sound levels in a working
environment.
The report suggests that workplace exposure
to both infrasound and ultrasound often exceeds
current guidelines.
There’s concern too that the guidelines
are too low, and outdated: coming from research
that’s 40 years old.
And even then the evidence for the guidelines
isn’t strong enough, they are based on the
average response of small group, often of
adult males.
The researchers back then didn’t didn’t
reach any strong conclusions, just preliminary
guidelines, believing that more research would
be done.
But in the ensuing decades, not much has changed.
So basically the lead author is saying…
“more research is needed”.
But there is evidence that infrasounds cause
more than just headaches.
Some researchers think it might be responsible
for that creepy “haunted house feeling”.
One paper published in the journal of the
Society for Psychical Research suggests that
a standing sound wave of specifically 18.9
hertz is responsible for some of the spooky
happenings in their lab.
Researchers at Coventry University kept seeing
moving things out of the corners of their
eyes, their hair kept standing on end, they
felt simply dreadful anytime they were in
the lab.
But one day they noticed a piece of equipment
was vibrating without an apparent cause, and
discovered that an extractor fan was creating
a standing wave at, you guess it, 18.9 hertz.
When they turned off the fan, one of the authors
described the feeling as “if a huge weight
was lifted”.
And researchers have tested this on a larger
audience.
Literally.
British scientists played music to a large
auditorium filled with people...and slipped
infrasound into some of the songs.
Some people in the audience said they felt
“uneasy or sorrowful, getting chills down
the spine or nervous feelings of revulsion
or fear” when the songs contained infrasound.
Spooky right?
No, it’s science.
But don’t be so put off by soundwaves yet.
Not all of them are creepy! in fact soundwaves
can do some pretty cool stuff!
To learn more about how scientists are harnessing
the power of sound, check out this episode
right here.
TestTube now has a newsletter!
Get a weekly round-up of our most popular
videos across all our shows at TestTube.com/fwd
So have you ever gotten that creepy feeling?
Or felt sick in your office or school for
no reason?
Do you think it was infrasound?
tell me your stories down below